Hablemos de enlaces de hidrógeno. Aquí están
representadas tres tipos diferentes de moléculas:
a la izquierda tenemos amoniaco, cada molécula de
amoniaco tiene 1 nitrógeno unido a 3 hidrógenos;
en medio tenemos algo con lo que probablemente
estás muy familiarizado, de hecho forma parte
de ti, es agua, cada oxígeno está unido
a 2 hidrógenos; y, luego, a la derecha,
tenemos fluoruro de hidrógeno, cada flúor está
unido a 1 hidrógeno. Ahora, ¿por qué estos tipos
de moléculas son interesantes?, ¿y eso qué
tiene que ver con los enlaces de hidrógeno?
La respuesta simple es que en cada uno de estos
casos tenemos hidrógeno unido a un átomo mucho
más electronegativo; aunque estos son enlaces
covalentes, van a ser enlaces covalentes polares.
Vamos a tener un momento dipolar de enlace que
va del hidrógeno al átomo más electronegativo,
del hidrógeno al átomo más electronegativo,
del hidrógeno al átomo más electronegativo.
El átomo más electronegativo va a acaparar los
electrones, los electrones van a pasar más tiempo
alrededor de éste, de modo que ese extremo de las
moléculas va a tener una carga negativa parcial,
y luego los extremos con el hidrógeno van a tener
cargas positivas parciales. Otra forma de pensar
en esto es que, si agregamos estos momentos
dipolares, tendremos un dipolar neto para la
molécula completa, que se vería como algo así.
Entonces estamos tratando con moléculas polares
y la polaridad proviene de la asimetría y de tener
un átomo muy electronegativo unido al hidrógeno.
El oxígeno es un átomo muy electronegativo
unido al hidrógeno Este extremo de la molécula
es parcialmente negativo, estos extremos de la
molécula son parcialmente positivos. Para el
fluoruro de hidrógeno este extremo es parcialmente
positivo, este extremo es parcialmente negativo.
Así que, ¿qué crees que podría pasar cuando estas
moléculas interactúan entre sí? Que el extremo
de nitrógeno de este amoniaco podría ser atraído
por uno de estos hidrógenos que tienen una carga
parcialmente positiva o este hidrógeno con carga
parcialmente positiva podría ser atraído por este
nitrógeno que tiene una carga parcialmente
negativa. Y esta atracción entre el extremo
de hidrógeno parcialmente positivo y el extremo
parcialmente negativo de otra molécula son enlaces
de hidrógeno, y son una fuerza intermolecular que
se sumará a la fuerza intermolecular total como
las fuerzas de dispersión de London, lo que te
hace tener un punto de ebullición más elevado de
lo que tendrías si sólo consideraras las fuerzas
de dispersión de London. Y para que quede claro,
puedes mirar esta gráfica, puedes ver que todas
estas moléculas están formadas por elementos
del periodo 2 e hidrógeno, de hecho todas estas
moléculas tienen masas molares similares: metano,
amoniaco, fluoruro de hidrógeno y agua. Si sólo
pensáramos en las fuerzas de dispersión de London,
las fuerzas de dispersión de London son
proporcionales a la polarizabilidad de
una molécula, que es proporcional al tamaño de
la nube de electrones que es proporcional a la
masa molar. Y hablando en general, a medida
que avanzamos de las moléculas formadas con
elementos del periodo 2, a las de elementos
del periodo 3, a los elementos del periodo 4,
a los elementos del periodo 5, se puede ver
que, conforme la masa molar de estas moléculas
aumenta hay una tendencia en general a la alza
del punto de ebullición, y eso se debe a las
fuerzas de dispersión de London. Pero en cualquier
periodo ves una separación, en particular hay una
gran separación de las moléculas formadas con
oxígeno, flúor y nitrógeno. Estas moléculas,
a pesar de tener masas molares similares, tienen
puntos de ebullición muy diferentes, por lo que
debe haber otro tipo de fuerzas intermoleculares
en juego más allá de las fuerzas de dispersión de
London. Y la respuesta simple es: sí, lo que hay
en juego son los enlaces de hidrógeno. Ahora quizá
te preguntarás: "Bueno, vemos que estas moléculas
formadas con elementos del periodo 3 e hidrógeno,
o con elementos del periodo 4 e hidrógeno,
tampoco tienen el mismo punto de ebullición,
aunque se esperaría que tuvieran fuerzas de
dispersión de London similares porque tienen masas
molares similares". Y la separación que vemos
aquí en los puntos de ebullición también se debe
a otras cosas aparte de las fuerzas de dispersión
de London, en particular estarían en juego las
fuerzas dipolo dipolo. Pero lo que podemos ver
es que la separación es mucho mayor en estas
moléculas formadas con nitrógeno e hidrógeno,
flúor e hidrógeno y oxígeno e hidrógeno,
y eso se debe a que los enlaces de hidrógeno
pueden ser vistos como la forma más fuerte
de las fuerzas dipolo dipolo. Los enlaces de
hidrógeno son un caso especial de fuerzas dipolo
dipolo. Cuando hablamos de enlaces de hidrógeno,
generalmente estamos hablando de un dipolo de
enlace específico: el enlace entre hidrógeno
y un átomo más electronegativo como nitrógeno,
oxígeno y flúor, de modo que estamos hablando
específicamente sobre esa parte de la molécula,
esa parte de hidrógeno que tiene una carga
parcialmente positiva y que es atraída por el
extremo parcialmente negativo de otra molécula.
Entonces, cuando hablamos de interacciones
dipolo dipolo, en general se trata realmente de un
dipolo de enlace con enlaces de hidrógeno versus
un dipolo molecular neto. Puedes imaginar que
ni siquiera tienen que ser enlaces de hidrógeno
entre moléculas similares, podrías tener enlaces
de hidrógeno entre una molécula de amoniaco y una
molécula de agua o entre una molécula de agua y
una molécula de fluoruro de hidrógeno. Y mencioné
que estos son muy importantes en Biología. Esto de
aquí es un acercamiento del ADN. Podemos ver que
los pares de bases en el ADN... Imagina los
peldaños de la escalera, están formados por
enlaces de hidrógeno entre pares de bases,
entonces estos enlaces de hidrógeno son lo
suficientemente fuertes para mantener esa doble
hélice unida, pero no son tan fuertes como para
no poder ser separados cuando es hora de replicar
o transcribir el ADN. Y aprenderás más sobre eso
en clase de Biología. Los enlaces de hidrógeno
también son importantes en las proteínas. En la
clase de Biología aprendes que las proteínas
están formadas por cadenas de aminoácidos
y la función está fuertemente influenciada
por la forma de esa proteína. Y esa forma
está influenciada por enlaces de hidrógeno
que podrían formarse entre los aminoácidos
que componen la proteína. Así que los enlaces de
hidrógeno están en todas partes, en este momento
hay muchos enlaces de hidrógeno en tu cuerpo,
no sólo por el ADN, principalmente porque eres
mayormente agua. De modo que la vida, tal como la
conocemos, no existiría sin enlaces de hidrógeno.